Silence.
Good afternoon, John.
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you okay.
At least for now.
How was it?
Well, it was a really intensive week,
actually.
Shortly speaking, I have wrote in around
5,000 lines of code for every day.
At least reviewing them.
And that was a lot, yeah.
Unfortunately, because of that,
I didn't do anything about English.
And I'm not really prepared for the
lesson, but we'll see what we can do.
Yeah, LLM have written everything,
but I still have to review all this.
What about your week?
Was it uneventful?
That's good that you're feeling better.
Yeah, okay.
Why wouldn't we start the lesson?
Thanks for the demonstration.
It seems like the first one was the one.
Yeah, this one.
We should see the green areas.
Yeah, those ones.
It sounds like a good plan.
As you said, we can answer some questions.
And before or after that, review some
previous ones.
Okay.
Okay, before I will try to answer it.
The same thing as for the previous answer,
that I don't have an experience fixing
some production bugs.
But in this way, we can answer kind of the
same.
We can describe the approach.
Usually, people do.
And then say something that I don't have
such an experience.
Maybe because I'm just good enough at my
major.
All right.
So we're talking about an emergency when
some sort of bug reached the production.
First of all, we have to analyze and
prioritize how crucial it is.
Sometimes we can fix it with just a minor
commit.
Sometimes it's crucial enough to roll
back.
For example, if it reaches some
interactions with the customers,
so they can purchase their requests.
In this case, it's probably fair enough to
roll back and fix everything at the first
step.
I did it quite fast, sorry.
And yeah, the last part is something
like...
Unfortunately, during my career,
I have never faced such a situation.
Which tells us maybe that I'm good at my
major enough.
Encounter.
It seems like it is.
We definitely had some minor bugs that
appear after a few weeks of release.
But at the time, we already fixed them on
our dev branch.
And again, at the time that they
reappeared, just a few days before the
next release.
So it's not that big.
And yeah, I think I didn't have such an
experience in my entire career.
Yeah,
that's much better.
All right.
All right, so...
This way, okay, I get it.
Of course, I have some unimpactful bugs in
my career.
Or we can say it in a little bit different
way.
Some minor bugs in my career that they
were unimpactful.
So...
We either had to just apply a minor fix.
Or wait for another release and fix
everything in our dev branch.
A hot fix, maybe?
Until next schedule.
Oh, yeah.
Now I see it.
That's a better ending.
We're telling basically that even if we
didn't have such a scenario, we still have
an experience.
At least some of it.
I didn't hear about this one.
We will check it later.
Okay.
Ah, yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
That's a solid way to prioritize things,
John.
I kind of had a quite similar but in the
same way simpler picture of prioritizing
by putting on the board the business value
in the first place.
But this thing is better because it has
four metrics.
So we can answer something.
Yes, back to the answer.
It's not my answer yet.
I'm just thinking about it.
We can answer something like that's
usually the priority already identified by
contact managers or team leaders.
And as an engineer, we can follow it.
But if it's not,
and as an engineer, we can follow it.
We can usually follow it.
Uh-huh.
Interesting word.
Okay.
If it's not, and we got a responsibility
in our own,
we can...
If it's not, and we have our own
responsibility, or something like this,
I'm not really confident.
We can use some metrics to value tasks and
prioritize them.
I don't know.
Is it necessary to mention RISE here?
Something like RISE, for example.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Stakeholders.
Uh-huh.
Like RISE, for instance.
And we have to finish somehow this answer.
Maybe.
Or
something like...
I will give you a role variant.
By using such methodologies and...
By using such methodologies and having
established process, we can extract as
many business value from our current
situation, as many as we could.
As many as we can.
Something like that.
The main thing is that we will get as many
business value as we can.
Okay.
Let me read it once again.
Yeah.
Usually, the priority is identified by the
product managers, team leads, and
stakeholders.
As an engineer, we can usually follow the
value set in terms of what gets addressed
first.
However, if it's not, we have our own
responsibility to verify the priority of
the completing activities using priority
methodologies like RISE, for instance.
By using such methodologies, we have
established process in place.
And by using such methodologies and having
established processes in place,
we can extract the business values and
impact from current situation and identify
as many priorities as we have.
Yeah.
I like it.
I also have a note about it.
Yeah.
I never heard anything about it.
But the closest thing I know is that
usually in villages, some farmers get
birches for chickens.
Something like that.
Maybe that's something about it.
So they're literally climbing up and
sleeping on some branches.
Wow.
I never heard about it.
Interesting.
I wonder how they claim.
Maybe I will get some videos about it.
Okay.
The question is yes or no.
And of course, we're answering yes.
And the next question, the main thing is
how.
So how we did it, what especially I did,
et cetera.
As always, let's first talk about how we
can the approach for this answer.
So in my case, it wasn't a general
situation because we got a new employee
that got quite the same, that was the same
intelligence as me.
And the main thing I have to, I got to.
Oh, my God.
Give me a second, please.
Okay.
The main thing that I was supposed to do
is to onboard him and provide a few,
a few documentations.
Provided a few documentations.
And yeah, because at the time,
we got a mindset that this employee had
to, had to be self-sustained and have to
not require any of mentoring, any of,
we don't even have to review the code he
did.
That was the mental model.
So, of course, I get an experience of
onboarding a new developer, but it was
much simpler than the usual, some usual
cases.
All right.
And using this experience, how can we
answer this question?
We have an, okay.
It will be something like, during my
career, I was lucky enough to get an
opportunity to mentor and onboarding a new
developer in our team.
To mentor and onboard a new developer in
our team.
Okay.
We don't have, we don't have to tell the
story.
We just have a few sentences.
I'm thinking about what exactly should I
provide to answer how I did it.
Usually the team wants that the new
stakeholder.
Oh my God.
During this, I don't know.
I'm just getting so many Russian-specific
options to express, and I'm trying to
translate them.
It's not really possible.
And I'm rolling back and trying it again
and again and again and again.
Self-sufficient.
Okay.
And the next part is about mentoring,
right?
I think I'm, yeah.
I'm just, you know, in these kinds of
situations, I think I'm not really
prepared for this question in general,
because I have tried to answer it in
Russian in my head.
In parallel, and I not really succeeded
either.
It's okay.
It just explains why I'm so slow right
now.
Okay.
About mentoring.
What I did in my experience, before
answering, before answering what I did in
my personal experience.
Since the person was qualified enough,
the prior thing I did was during the code
review.
Even if it was a senior engineer,
we still have to synchronize the way we
work together.
So everyone will follow the code standards
described in the documents.
And even a senior could lack some...
Oh, my God.
Where is that word?
Hold on a second.
Yeah.
Thanks, John.
Maybe the proper mindset is to get on
board my experience by coaching people
some basic stuff in programming.
Because I don't have a commercial
experience, but I have a bunch of
uncommercial ones.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
And how we can apply them to this answer.
This is the junior developer.
So, okay.
We will get a bunch of code reviews,
of course.
We will review the code and provide some
feedback.
Yes.
And if it's challenging enough,
we can also apply a short call and pay
program some things.
Even the juniors work.
Okay, okay.
We spend more time reviewing the junior
engineers' work than experienced
professionals.
So we can provide some...
So we can provide a detailed feedback.
This will allow us to...
Some detailed feedback.
And if the situation is challenging
enough...
We can also...
It's just...
If the situation is challenging enough,
we also can apply...
We can also add some...
Some direct communication with a person.
In order to...
In order to ensure something.
I know.
Yeah, thanks.
Yeah, it must be a little bit shorter
because we still have to end it somehow.
It kind of lacks of ending, but yeah,
it's okay for now.
Mm-hmm.
The time...
I had to learn a new phrase.
Okay.
About a time.
So again, it's not supposed to be a story
or passage, but we have to provide some
details about what techniques we used or
something like that.
It was a hard summer day.
Yeah.
You're describing my city right now.
Yeah, it might be rural.
I didn't know about this, though.
But yeah, I can imagine.
I face just...
It's in a different way from my
facilities.
Okay.
Well, back to the question.
The time.
It will be something like...
Yeah, in one of my last positions,
I talked about one specific technology
that the team required.
That everyone in the team used,
and it was required in order to be
self-sustained.
Be self-sustained.
The tool was quite complex, and it...
Okay, let's use it again.
And it requires a lot of investments in
order to achieve a progress.
In order to achieve a progress.
The main thing I did is...
Okay, okay.
Yeah, let's start with something.
The main thing I did was simple.
I prioritized this thing over others.
And I also spent some extra time besides
my...
Besides my...
How can I express it?
Besides my work time, something like that.
I spent some...
Ah, yeah, thanks.
I prioritized this item above others and
spent some personal time.
And spent some personal time.
I also asked...
Ah, yeah.
I also asked my lead.
So I will get a few extra tasks that
required using this specific tool.
So I can practice it.
In parallel while learning it.
We'll get a practice.
Experience learning the tool.
In a real world.
Ah, in a real world.
Yeah, okay, okay.
And that's it, actually.
We also...
We could add some finishing, but it's not
really necessary here.
Wow.
In the real world, I'm still struggling
with this one.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm thinking from what I can even
start.
So, okay, again, the question is how.
So how you do it and what specific things
you're bringing up.
I even got enough luck to be able to...
Oh, God.
Okay, hold on a second.
I just faced with another Russian option
of expression.
Let me translate it first.
Oh, God.
I don't think we will understand each
other.
But okay, the translator says me something
like to lobby for my own case.
So it's simple.
The translator suggesting there's
something like to lobby for one's case.
Using simple words, what it means that at
my position, I wanted to implement an
internal feature for my applications.
And, of course, it helped the business
somehow.
But primarily, it was my initiative.
And I asked for it for quite a long.
And I finally get a chance to implement
it.
And got a few time resources for it.
That's what I'm trying to say.
I wonder, is there a more professional way
to explain it?
Yeah, and that's...
Okay, okay.
And the main thing is that that feature
was large enough.
At the beginning of our today's lesson,
I said that for the last few days,
I wrote a few thousands of code every day.
And that's because I was writing that
specific feature.
It was so large that I even decided to
create a storyline for this.
And split it for some lower tasks.
It was one of my first experiences
managing this kind of stuff.
And unfortunately, I kind of underestimate
this one.
And yeah, because of that, I still...
Not still.
I finished it just yesterday.
But initially, it has to be finished at
the end of the previous week.
Yeah, but it's still experience.
And I believe I learned something.
Anyway, so story points.
Splitting the large task to a smaller one.
And applying some techniques to estimate
it properly.
From what can I begin?
Optimistic activities.
There are smaller and concise rather than
an overall estimate.
On the main goal of the requests.
I have one sub-question.
Should we mention something about story
points?
All these metrics that everyone is using.
Should we mention that we're using these
ones?
Or it's so generally widespread that we
don't even have to bother ourselves by
mentioning that.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yeah, this is basically how we estimate
the task in a real world.
And yeah, I'm looking at the way we
structure the answer.
For context.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm also thinking about that.
We're usually trying to put off a specific
tool or thing.
And talk about things in a general way.
But in this answer we're specifically
talking about Jira.
Some specific mythology of estimating the
tasks.
The story points.
Epics and user stories, etc.
So I guess it's because it's so widely
spread that everyone is already aware
about it.
Isn't it?
Okay.
Well, yeah.
I'm just usually thinking about that the
more advanced your level, the longer you
can construct the sentences.
The same way it applies probably for any
languages.
As well as Russian, as well as even
programming languages.
And yeah, for example, the second sentence
in that question was impressive.
It's quite above my level, but yeah,
I like it anyway.
Yeah, it's good, don't get me wrong.
Yeah, at least we get the raw option here.
While I was thinking during the lesson as
well, maybe I can bring something to make
your life a little bit easier.
So all of my answers will be recorded and
translated to script directly.
Without needing to write it by hand.
So I can answer it.
Everything will be written in a document
or somewhere.
And based on that raw output, we can
translate it to some better option.
Maybe it will be a little bit better.
It's just my thoughts at the moment.
Yes.
Yeah,
I agree.
It probably will be quite a busy weekend.
I have to do some things.
Yeah, let's just say something,
because it will be quite a long story
otherwise.
But I will still try to find some time at
least to review the answers, review the
transcription of our lessons.
I still have free transcriptions,
freehold transcriptions to review.
I established the system that will provide
me the feedback and the short output.
But I haven't even opened it yet,
unfortunately.
Craig is valuable, of course.
How rude we are.
Hello, Craig, how are you doing?
OK, John, I hope you will get a nice
weekend.
And we'll see you together next Tuesday.
Yeah.
Thank you.
See you.
Bye-bye.